Like Infinity War before it, Avengers: Endgame
is a marvel of storytelling, but is the execution
perfect?
Not really.
Throughout its three-hour runtime, Endgame
takes some narrative turns that teeter on
the edge of nonsense, and some of screenwriters'
choices threaten to ruin the movie if you
think about them too hard.
Here are the biggest plot holes in Avengers:
Endgame that everybody just ignored.
Strange dissonance
During the film's time heist, Bruce Banner
visits the Sanctum Sanctorum in 2012 New York
City.
He's searching for Dr. Strange, to borrow
the time stone he's known to guard.
But instead of Strange, he finds the Ancient
One, Strange's mentor, who doesn't meet the
doctor until the events of his movie in 2016.
Despite Strange not yet being the Sorcerer
Supreme, the Ancient One has full knowledge
of who he is, and hearing that he gives away
the Time Stone in the future is enough to
convince her to give up her own stone.
That's how much she trusts Strange, saying,
"Strange is meant to be the best of us."
It's presented as a foregone conclusion, a
predestined future that she's already aware
of.
But this doesn't match up with what we've
seen before.
In the Doctor Strange movie, the Ancient One
presents private doubts as to whether she'll
even train Strange, confiding in Mordo that
she cannot take him on as a student.
Mordo has to convince her to train him, which
flatly contradicts Endgame.
"I cannot lead another gifted student to power
only to lose him to the darkness."
It'd make sense for the Ancient One to put
up a front for Strange himself, but why would
she doubt him when he's not even in the room?
It's not magic, just a little plot hole between
movies.
"I never saw your future.
Only its possibilities."
Delivered to your door
Just as Peter Quill sends the Avengers' plan
off the rails in Infinity War, Nebula nearly
ruins everything in Endgame.
Thanks to her always-on wi-fi, the cyborg
daughter of Thanos is found, captured, and
replaced by her younger counterpart in 2014,
with her past self following the Avengers
into the future on Thanos' behalf.
Once there, she flips some switches on the
team's quantum tunnel, targets Thanos' ship,
and opens a portal to bring him through.
Afterwards, the final battle kicks in so fast
you're left with no time to figure out what
exactly just happened.
When the Avengers' Nebula is sent back to
help retrieve the Power Stone, she leaves
with only enough Pym Particles for a return
trip, particles which 2014 Nebula presumably
uses in her place.
She then uses the quantum tunnel to target
Thanos' ship and pull it into the future,
with Thanos' ship somehow able to enter the
Quantum Realm without the help of any Pym
particles or technology.
Also, if it's possible for the 2014 Nebula
to target objects and pull them through time,
why didn't the Avengers do exactly that with
the Infinity Stones themselves?
If Nebula can bring a ship through, why couldn't
they bring some rocks through?
You can come up with all kinds of solutions
for this, and reportedly, the Russo brothers
have begun explaining in interviews that the
Pym particles were reverse engineered by Thanos
and Ebony Maw.
But even if that's the case, the movie doesn't
show any of this, it just starts the explosions
and crosses its fingers, hoping you won't
think too hard about it.
Snaps all around
At the end of Infinity War, Thanos kills half
of the universe with a snap of his fingers.
It's a flourish that's ripped straight out
of the comic books, and a gesture that became
instantly iconic.
But Endgame treats snapping your fingers as
though it's an essential part of the way the
Gauntlet works, so much so that Captain Marvel
is able to stop Thanos from destroying the
universe during the movie's final battle by
holding onto his fingers, preventing him from
pulling off a snap.
But here's the thing, you shouldn't have to
snap your fingers to exert the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet.
This isn't how it works in the comics or the
movies.
While the Thanos of the movies does usually
close his fist while wielding the Gauntlet's
powers, it doesn't appear that he really has
to, and the fact that the snap does anything
kind of proves that.
It just seems like something he does more
for the audience.
Once Thanos gets the Gauntlet on his hand,
he should be able to rewrite reality with
little more than sheer willpower, from what
the movies and the comics that inspired them
have shown us, you don't need to snap your
fingers to have it grant your wish.
Rescue signal
Relative to all the movies that came before
it, Endgame is like a fire hose of fan-service,
especially the final battle, in which dozens
of characters line up to fight like a living
comics splash page.
It's an event that fans have spent years waiting
for, but plenty of people still had to ask,
what exactly is Pepper Potts doing there?
We can readily accept the notion that the
CEO of Stark Industries has become proficient
at piloting her own Rescue armor over the
years.
It's not a stretch of the imagination that
she'd learn the ropes of combat off-screen,
especially after Iron Man 3 saw her vanquish
the villain herself while briefly supercharged
by Extremis.
She has as much of a right to fight as anybody
else in the MCU, but the question is, who
called her?
The epic return of all the Avengers post-revival
is implied to have been coordinated by Dr.
Strange, who got a hold of the other sorcerers
on Earth and immediately set about reuniting
every fighter for a showdown at Avengers HQ.
But how did he know to call Pepper, who didn't
suit up in her own Iron Man armor until long
after Strange was dead?
They only met for like a second.
Would he even know where she lives?
How'd that phone call go?
"Hey, Pepper, it's Steve.
Heading upstate for the final battle, come
through, bring a gun or something."
Whatever the specifics are of who got ahold
of her so fast, we now live in a universe
where Pepper freaking Potts got a shot off
on Thanos, and that's pretty remarkable, whether
you like it or not.
Renewable resources
Much is made of the stakes at play in the
Avengers' time heist gambit.
On top of playing with forces they don't quite
understand, facing a threat that soundly beat
them before, the Avengers are also dealing
with limited resources.
As Scott Lang tells everyone, the time travel
trickery of the Quantum Realm relies entirely
on the proprietary Pym Particles invented
by Hank Pym, who in death is unable to create
any more of them.
If they use up their supply on the heist without
succeeding, they lose.
But the answer to this conundrum is right
in front of the Avengers the whole time, and
it's kind of shocking that Scott, a career
thief, doesn't think of it.
Instead of starting off their journey by trying
to get the stones, why didn't they begin by
going back in time and stealing all of the
Pym Particles they were going to need?
If the past can be mined for Infinity Stones
and magic hammers, it can certainly be mined
for Pym Particles.
Even if they use them up and don't return
them, Hank can just invent more.
Sure, it's possible that stealing the particles
and not replacing them will create a slightly
different timeline, but this hardly feels
like a big transgression, considering all
the other maverick improvisation the team
gets up to during the heist.
The only reason the writers didn't take this
route is probably because it would've lowered
the stakes.
Captain America's bogus journey
Everyone's got an opinion about Captain America
going back into the past to live a life with
Peggy Carter.
Some people love it, while others think it
betrays his character.
We're not concerned about any of that, we're
just trying to figure out how Old Cap showed
up in the prime timeline.
Endgame makes its time travel rules very clear.
It's not Back to the Future style, where changing
the past can change the future.
Here's how Professor Hulk explains it:
"If you travel to the past, that past becomes
your future, and your former present becomes
the past, which can't now be changed by your
new future."
It's all pretty simple, changes to the past
cause different timelines.
So why and how does Captain America going
into the past in the prime timeline lead to
him growing old and living a life in the prime
timeline?
"The world has changed.
None of us can go back."
In the MCU so far, Steve Rogers has gone under
the ice, hibernated for nearly 70 years, and
been revived to live a decade or so as one
of Earth's mightiest heroes.
As Endgame closes, he goes back into the past
to catch up on that date he missed with Peggy.
That past is now his future, a new future,
independent of the one he previously hibernated
in.
It should have caused an alternate timeline.
Instead, it's implied that Steve went to the
past of the prime timeline, which completely
goes against how Hulk says time travel works.
Whose shield is it, anyway?
Some people believe that Steve going into
the past and living out his days as Peggy's
husband is a simple closed loop, that he always
married Peggy, and just stayed off-screen
during young Steve's reunion with old Peggy
during their meetup in The Winter Soldier.
In this theory, there have always been two
Steves, one's just been secretly retired.
"He saved over 1,000 men, including the one
who would become my husband, as it turned
out."
That's a weird way to put it, but okay.
Here's another question, then: Where did Old
Steve get his shield?
Endgame's final battle results in the destruction
of Captain America's shield, leaving it cleaved
in two by Thanos' blade.
He does not take the shield back to the past
with him.
But when Old Steve shows up next to the pond,
he has a shield in pristine condition.
How?
If Steve's time-hopping life is a closed loop,
then there should only be one shield to go
around.
If Cap somehow stole his own shield while
his younger self was under the ice, then that
would mean there would be no shield for his
younger self to receive upon waking up, creating
exactly the kind of paradox that this movie's
time travel rules are supposed to avoid.
So is Old Cap from another timeline, and just
came over to drop a shield off with Falcon?
If so, how'd he get back to the prime timeline
as a 100-something-year-old man?
Maybe it's not the real Cap at all, maybe
it's just a gigantic plot hole that it'd be
best to stop thinking about.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.